horrible beyond conception was the
change which had taken place and my best
friend Crawford Tillinghast
I had not seen him since that day two
months and a half before when he told me
toward what goal his physical and
metaphysical researches were leading
when he had answered my odd and almost
framed remonstrances by driving me from
his laboratory and his house in a burst
of fanatical rage I had known that he
now remained mostly shut in the Attic
laboratory without a curse at electrical
machine eating little and excluding even
the servants but I had not thought that
a brief period of 10 weeks could so
alter and disfigure any human creature
it is not pleasant to see a stout man
suddenly grown thin and it is even worse
when the baggy skin becomes yellow
degrade the eyes sunken circled and
uncannily glowing the forehead veined
and corrugated and the hands tremulous
and twitching and if added to this there
be a repellent unkempt Ness a wild
disorder of dress a bushiness of dark
hair white at the roots and an unchecked
growth of white beard on a face once
clean-shaven the cumulative effect is
quite shocking but such was the aspect
of Crawford Tillinghast
on the night his half coherent message
brought me to his door after my weeks of
exile such was the specter that trembled
as it admitted me candle in hand and
glanced furtively over its shoulder as a
fearful of unseen things in the ancient
lowly house sent back from benevolent
Street that Crawford Tillinghast should
ever have studied science and philosophy
was a mistake these things should be
left to the frigid and impersonal
investigator for they offer two equally
tragic alternatives to the man of
feeling inaction despair if he fail in
his quest and terrors unutterable and
unimaginable if he succeed till aghast
had once been the prey of failure
solitary and melancholy but now I knew
with nauseating fears of my own that he
was the prey of success I had indeed
warned him ten weeks before when he
burst forth with his tale of what he
felt himself about to discover he had
been flushed and excited then talking in
a high and unnatural though always
pedantic voice
what do we know he had said of the world
and the universe about us our means of
receiving impressions are absurdly few
and our notions of surrounding objects
infinitely narrow we see things only as
we are constructed to see them and can
gain no idea of their absolute nature
with five feeble senses we pretend to
comprehend the boundlessly complex
cosmos yet other beings with a wider
stronger or different range of senses
might not only see very differently the
things we see but might see in study
whole worlds of matter energy and life
which lie close at hand yet can never be
detected with the senses we have I've
always believed at such strange
inaccessible worlds exist that our very
elbows and now I believe I have found a
way to break down the barriers I'm not
joking within 24 hours that machine near
the table will generate waves acting on
unrecognized sense organs that exist in
us as atrophied or rudimentary vestiges
those waves will open up to us many
vistas unknown to man and several
unknown to anything we consider organic
life we shall see that at which dogs
howl in the dark and that at which cats
prick up their ears after midnight we
shall see these things and other things
which no breathing creature has yet seen
we shall over leap time space and
dimensions and without bodily motion
peer to the bottom of creation when
tilling gasps said these things I
remonstrated for I knew him well enough
to be frightened rather than amused but
he was a fanatic and drove me from the
house now he was no less a fanatic but
his desire to speak had conquered his
presentment and he had written me
imperative ly in a hand I could scarcely
recognize as I entered the abode of the
friends so subtly metamorphosed into his
shiver and gargoyle I became infected
with the terror which seemed stalking in
all the shadows the words and belief
expressed ten weeks before seemed bodied
forth in the darkness beyond the small
circle of candlelight and I sickened at
the hollow altered voice of my host
I wish the servants were about and did
not like it when he said they had all
left three days previously it seemed
strange that old Gregory at least should
desert his master without telling his
tried a friend design
it was he who had given me all the
information I had of tilling ghast after
I was repulsed and rage and I soon
subordinated all my fears to my growing
curiosity and fascination just what
Crawford Tillinghast now wished of me I
can only guess but that he had some
stupendous secret or discovery to impart
I could not doubt before I had protested
of his unnatural prying into the
unthinkable now that he had evidently
succeeded to some degree I almost shared
his spirit terrible though the cost of
victory appeared up through the dark
emptiness of the house I followed the
bobbing candle in the hand of this
shaking parody of a man the electricity
seemed to be turned off and when I asked
my guide he said it was for a definite
reason it would be too much I would not
dare he continued to mutter I especially
noted his new habit of muttering for it
was not like him to talk to himself
we entered the laboratory in the attic
and I observed that detestable
electrical machine glowing with a sickly
sinister violet luminosity it was
connected with a powerful chemical
battery but seemed to be receiving no
current for I recalled that in its
experimental stage it had sputtered and
purred when in action in reply to my
question till and gasps mumbled that
this permanent glow was not electrical
in any sense that I could understand
he now seated me near the machine said
that it was on my right and turned a
switch somewhere below the crowning
cluster of glass bulbs the usual
sputtering began turned to a whine and
terminated in a drone so soft as to
suggest a return to silence meanwhile
the luminosity increased waned again
then assumed a pale Loutre color or
blend of colors which I could neither
place nor describe till and gas had been
watching me and noted my puzzled
expression do you know what that is he
whispered that is ultraviolet he
chuckled oddly at my surprise you
thought ultraviolet was invisible and so
it is but you can see that and many
other invisible things now listen to me
the waves from that thing are waking a
thousand sleeping senses in us senses
which we inherit from eons of evolution
from the state of detached electrons to
the state of organic humanity
I've seen the truth and I intend to show
it to you do you wonder how it will seem
I will tell you here tilling gasp seated
himself directly opposite me blowing out
his candle and staring hideously into my
eyes your existing sense organs ears
first I think will pick up many of the
impressions for their closely connected
with the dormant organs then there will
be others you've heard of the pineal
gland I laugh at the shallow
endocrinologist fellow dupe and fellow
parvenu of the Freudian that gland is
the great sense organ of organs I have
found out it is like sight in the end
and transmits visual pictures to the
brain if you are normal that is the way
you ought to get most of it I mean get
most of the evidence from beyond I
looked about the immense attic room with
a sloping south wall dimly lit by rays
which the everyday eye cannot see the
far corners were all shadows and the
whole place took on a hazy unreality
which obscured its nature and invited
the imagination to symbolism and
phantasm during the interval that
tilling gassed was long silent I fancied
myself in some vast incredible temple of
long dead gods some vague edifice of
innumerable black stone columns reaching
up from a floor of damp slabs to a
cloudy height beyond the range of my
vision the picture was very vivid for a
while but gradually gave way to a more
horrible conception that of utter
absolute solitude in infinite sightless
soundless space there seemed to be a
void and nothing more and I felt a
childish fear which prompted me to draw
from my hip pocket the revolver I
carried after dark since the night I was
held up in East Providence then from the
farther most regions of remoteness the
sound softly glided into existence it
was infinitely faint subtly vibrant and
unmistakably musical but held a quality
of surpassing wildness which made its
impact feel like a delicate torture of
my whole body I felt sensations like
those one feels when accidentally
scratching ground glass simultaneously
there developed something like a cold
draught which apparently swept past me
from the direction of the distant sound
as I waited breathlessly I perceived
that both sound and wind were increasing
the effect being to give me an odd
notion of myself as tied to a pair of
rails in the path of a gigantic
approaching locomotive I began to speak
to tilling gassed and as I did so all
the unusual impressions abruptly
vanished I saw only the man the glowing
machines and the dim apartment
tilling gasps was grinning repulsively
at the revolver which I had almost
unconsciously drawn but from his
expression I was sure he had seen and
heard as much as I if not a great deal
more I whispered what I had experienced
and he bade me to remain as quiet and
receptive as possible don't move he
cautioned for in these rays we are able
to be seen as well as to see I told you
the servants left but I didn't tell you
how it was that thick-witted housekeeper
she turned on the lights downstairs
after I'd warned her not to and the
wires picked up sympathetic vibrations
it must have been frightful I could hear
the screams up here in spite of all I
was seeing and hearing from another
direction and later it was rather awful
to find those empty heaps of clothes
around the house mrs. Updike's clothes
were close to the front hall switch
that's how I know she did it it got them
all but so long as we don't move we're
fairly safe remember we're dealing with
the hideous world in which we are
practically helpless keep still the
combined shock of the revelation and of
the abrupt command gave me a kind of
paralysis and in my terror my mind again
opened to the impressions coming from
what tilling gas called beyond I was now
in a vortex of sound and motion with
confused pictures before my eyes I saw
the blurred outlines of the room but
from some point in space there seemed to
be pouring a seething column of
unrecognizable shapes or clouds
penetrating the solid roof at a point
ahead and to the right of me then I
glimpsed the temple-like effect again
but this time the pillars reached up
into an aerial ocean of light which sent
down one blinding beam along the path of
the cloudy column I had seen before
after that the scene was almost wholly
kaleidoscopic and in the jumble of sight
sounds and unidentified sense
impressions I felt that I was about to
dissolve or in some way lose the saw
form one definite flash I shall always
remember I seemed for an instant to
behold a patch of strange night sky
filled with shining revolving spheres
and as it proceeded I saw that the
glowing Suns formed a constellation or
galaxy of settled shape the shape being
the distorted face of Crawford
Tillinghast at another time I felt the
huge animate things brushing past me and
occasionally walking or drifting through
my supposedly solid body and thought I
saw tilling gasps look at them as though
his better trained senses could catch
them visually I recalled what he had
said of the pineal gland and wondered
what he saw with his preternatural eye
suddenly I myself became possessed of a
kind of augmented sight over and above
the luminous and shadowy chaos arose a
picture which though vague held the
elements of consistency and permanence
it was indeed somewhat familiar for the
unusual part was superimposed upon the
usual terrestrial scene much as a cinema
view may be thrown upon the painted
curtain of a theatre I saw the Attic
laboratory the electrical machine and
the unsightly form of tilling gassed
opposite me but of all the space
unoccupied by familiar objects not one
particle was vacant indescribable shapes
both alive and otherwise were mixed and
disgusting disarray and closed to every
known thing were worlds of alien unknown
entities it likewise seemed that all the
known things entered into the
composition of other unknown things and
vice-versa
foremost among the living objects were
inky jellyfish monstrosity x' which
flabbily quivered in harmony with the
vibrations from the machine they were
present and loathsome profusion and I
saw to my horror that they overlapped
that they were semi fluid and capable of
passing through one another and through
what we know is solids these things were
never still but seemed ever floating
about with some malignant purpose
sometimes they appeared to devour one
another
the attacker launching itself at its
victim and instantaneously obliterating
the latter from sight shudderingly
I felt that I knew what had obliterated
the unfortunate servants and could not
exclude the thing from my mind as I
strove to observe other properties of
the newly visible
that lies unseen around us but tilling
gas had been watching me and was
speaking you see them you see them you
see the things that float and flop about
you and through you every moment of your
life you see the creatures that form
what men call the pure air in the blue
sky have I not succeeded in breaking
down the barrier have I not shown you
worlds that no other living men have
seen I heard his scream through the
horrible chaos and looked at the wild
face thrust so offensively close to mine
his eyes were pits of flame and they
glared at me with what I now saw was
overwhelming hatred the machine drone
detestably you think those floundering
things wiped out the servants fool they
are harmless but the servants are gone
aren't they you tried to stop me you
discouraged me when I needed every drop
of encouragement I could get you are
afraid of the cosmic truth you damn
coward and now I've got you
what swept up the servants what made
them scream so loud don't know eh you'll
know soon enough look at me
listen to what I say do you suppose
there are really any such things as time
and magnitude do you fancy there are
such things as form or matter I tell you
I have struck depths that your little
brain can't picture I've seen beyond the
bounds of infinity and drawn down demons
from the stars
I have harnessed the shadows that stride
from world to world - so death and
madness space belongs to me do you hear
things are hunting me now the things
that devour and dissolve but I know how
to elude them it is you they will get as
they got the servants stirring dear sir
I told you it was dangerous to move I've
saved you so far by telling you to keep
still saved you to see more sights and
to listen to me if you had moved they
would have been at you long ago don't
worry they won't hurt you they didn't
hurt the servants it was the seeing that
made the poor devils scream so my pets
are not pretty for they come out of
places where aesthetic standards are
very different disintegration is quite
painless I assure you but I want you to
see them I almost saw them but I knew
how to stop you're curious I always knew
you were no scientist trembling a
trembling with anxiety to see the
ultimate things I have discovered why
don't you move then tired
well don't worry my friend for they're
coming look look Kersey look it's just
over your left shoulder what remains to
be told is very brief and may be
familiar to you from the newspaper
accounts the police heard a shot in the
old tilling gassed house and found us
there
tilling gas dead and me unconscious they
arrested me because the revolver was in
my hand but released me in three hours
after they found it was apoplexy which
had finished tilling gassed and saw that
my shot had been directed at the noxious
machine which now lay hopelessly
shattered on the laboratory floor I did
not tell very much of what I had seen
for I feared the coroner would be
skeptical but from the evasive outline I
did give the doctor told me that I had
undoubtedly been hypnotized by the
vindictive and homicidal madman I wish I
could believe that doctor it would help
my shaky nerves if I could dismiss what
I now have to think of the air in the
sky about and above me I never feel
alone or comfortable in a hideous sense
of pursuit sometimes comes chillingly on
me when I am weary what prevents me from
believing the doctor is one simple fact
that the police never found the bodies
of those servants whom they say Crawford
Tillinghast murdered
that very singular man
old dr. Heidegger once invited for
venerable friends to meet him in his
study there were three white bearded
gentleman mr. med born colonel Killigrew
and mr. Gascoigne and a withered gentle
woman whose name was the widow wicker
Lee they were all melancholy old
creatures who had been unfortunate in
life and whose greatest misfortune it
was that they were not long ago in their
graves
mr. med born in the vigor of his age had
been a prosperous merchant but had lost
it all by a frantic speculation and was
now little more than a mendicant Colonel
Killigrew had wasted his best years and
his health and substance in the pursuit
of sinful pleasures which had given
birth to a brood of pains such as the
gout and diverse other torments of soul
and body mr. Gascoigne was a ruined
politician a man of evil Fame or at
least had been so till time had buried
him from the knowledge of the present
generation and it made him obscure
instead of infamous as for the widow
Wieck early tradition tells us that she
was a great beauty in her day but for a
long while past she had lived in deep
seclusion on account of certain
scandalous stories which had prejudiced
the gentry of the town against her it is
a circumstance worth mentioning that
each of these three old gentleman mr.
med born colonel Killigrew and mr.
Gascoigne were early lovers of the widow
Wieck early and had once been on the
point of cutting each other's throats
for her sake and before proceeding
farther I will merely hint that dr.
Heidegger and all his four guests were
sometimes thought to be a little beside
themselves as is not unfrequently the
case with old people when worried either
by present troubles or woeful
recollections My dear old friends said
dr. Heidegger motioning them to be
seated
I'm desirous of your assistance and one
of those little experiments with which I
amuse myself here in my study if all the
stories were true
dr. Heidegger study must have been a
very curious place it was a dim
old-fashioned chamber festooned with
cobwebs and be sprinkled with antique
dust around the walls stood several
oaken bookcases
the lower shelves of which were filled
with rows of gigantic folios and
black-letter cortos and the upper with
little parchment covered duodecimo x'
over the central bookcase was a bronze
bust of Hippocrates with which according
to some authorities dr. Heidegger was
accustomed to hold consultations in all
difficult cases of his practice in the
obscurest corner of the room stood a
tall and narrow oaken closet with its
door ajar within which doubtfully
appeared a skeleton between two of the
bookcases hung a looking-glass
presenting its high and dusty plate with
an a tarnished gilt frame among many
wonderful stories related of this mirror
it was fabled that the spirits of all
the doctors deceased patients dwelt
within its verge and would stare him in
the face whenever he looked to the other
word the opposite side of the chamber
was ornamented with the full-length
portrait of a young lady arrayed in the
faded magnificence of silk satin and
brocade and with a visages faded as her
dress above half a century ago dr.
Heidegger had been on the point of
marriage with this young lady but being
affected with some slight disorder she
had swallowed one of her lover's
prescriptions and died on the bridal
evening the greatest curiosity of the
study remains to be mentioned it was a
ponderous folio volume bound in black
leather with a massive silver clasps
there were no letters on the back and
nobody could tell the title of the book
but it was well-known to be a book of
magic and once when a chambermaid had
lifted it merely to brush away the dust
the skeleton had rattled in its closet
the picture of the young lady had
stepped one foot upon the floor and
several ghastly faces had peeped forth
from the mirror while the brazen head of
Hippocrates frowned and said forbear
such was dr. Heidegger study on the
summer afternoon of our tale a small
round table as black as ebony stood in
the center of the room
sustaining a cut glass vase of beautiful
form and elaborate workmanship the
sunshine came through the window between
the heavy festoons of two faded curtains
and fell directly across this vase so
that a mild splendor was reflected from
it on the ash envisages of the five old
people who sat around for champagne
glasses were also on the table my dear
old friends repeated dr. Heidegger may I
reckon on your aid in performing an
exceedingly curious experiment now dr.
Heidegger was a very strange old
gentleman whose eccentricity had become
the nucleus for a thousand fantastic
stories some of these fables to my shame
be it spoken might possibly be traced
back to my known voracious self and if
any passages of the present tale should
startle the readers faith I must be
content to bear the stigma of a fiction
monger when the doctors for guests heard
him talk of his proposed experiment they
anticipated nothing more wonderful than
the murder of a mouse and an air pump or
the examination of a cobweb by the
microscope or some similar nonsense with
which he was constantly in the habit of
pestering his intimates but without
waiting for a reply
dr. Heidegger hobbled across the chamber
and returned with the same ponderous
folio bound in black leather which
common report affirmed to be a book of
magic on doing the silver clasps he
opened the volume and took from among
its black letter pages a rose or what
was once a rose though now the green
leaves and crimson petals had assumed
one brownish hue and the ancient flower
seemed ready to crumble to dust in the
doctors hands this Rose said dr.
Heidegger with a sigh the same withered
and crumbling flower blossomed five and
fifty years ago it was given me by
Sylvia Ward whose portrait hangs yonder
and I meant to wear it in my bosom at
our wedding five and fifty years that
has been treasured between the leaves of
this old volume now would you deem it
possible that this Rose of half a
century could ever bloom again nonsense
said the widow wick early with a peevish
toss of her head you might as well ask
whether an old woman's wrinkled face
could ever bloom again see answered dr.
Heidegger he uncovered the vase and
threw the faded rose into the water
which it contained at first it lay
lightly on the surface of the fluid
appearing to abide none of its moisture
soon however a singular change began to
be visible the crushed and dried petals
stirred and assumed a deepening tinge of
crimson as if the flower were reviving
from a deathlike slumber the slender
stalk and twigs of foliage became green
and there was the Rose of half a century
looking as fresh as when Sylvia Ward had
first given it to her lover it was
scarcely full-blown for some of its
delicate red leaves curled modestly
around its moist bosom within which two
or three dewdrops were sparkling that is
certainly a very pretty deception said
the doctors friends
carelessly however for they had
witnessed greater miracles at a
conjurors show pray how was it affected
did you never hear of the Fountain of
Youth
ask dr. Heidegger which Ponce de Leon
the Spanish adventurer went in search of
two or three centuries ago but did Ponce
de Leon ever find it said the widow
wicker Lea no
answered dr. Heidegger for he never
sought it in the right place
the famous Fountain of Youth if I am
rightly informed is situated in the
southern part of the Floridian Peninsula
not far from Lake macaco its source is
overshadowed by several gigantic
magnolias which though numberless
centuries old have been kept as fresh as
violets
by the virtues of this wonderful water
an acquaintance of mine knowing my
curiosity in such matters has sent me
what you see in the vase ahem said Carl
Killigrew who believed not a word of the
doctor's story and what may be the
effect of this fluid on the human frame
you shall judge for yourself my dear
colonel replied dr. Heidegger and all of
you my respected friends are welcome to
so much of this admirable fluid as may
restore to you the bloom of youth
my own part having had much trouble in
growing old I am in no hurry to grow
young again with your permission
therefore I will merely watch the
progress of the experiment while he
spoke dr. Heidegger had been filling the
for champagne glasses with the water of
the Fountain of Youth
it was apparently impregnated with an
effervescent gasp four little bubbles
were continually ascending from the
depths of the glasses and bursting and
silvery spray at the surface as the
liqueur diffused a pleasant perfume the
old people doubted not that it possessed
cordial and comfortable properties and
though utter skeptics as to its
rejuvenant power they were inclined to
swallow it at once
but dr. Heidegger besought them to stay
a moment before you drink my respectable
old friends said he it would be well
that with the experience of a lifetime
to direct you you should draw up a few
general rules for your guidance in
passing a second time through the perils
of youth think what a sin and a shame it
would be if with your peculiar
advantages you should not become
patterns of virtue and wisdom to all the
young people of the age the doctors for
venerable friends made him no answer
except by a feeble and tremulous laugh
so very ridiculous was the idea that
knowing how closely repentance treads
behind the steps of error they should
ever go astray again drink then said the
doctor bowing I rejoice that I have so
well selected the subjects of my
experiment with Paul's heed hands they
raised the glasses to their lips the
liquor if it really possessed such a
virtues as dr. Heidegger imputed to it
could not have been bestowed on four
human beings who needed it more woefully
they looked as if they had never known
what youth or pleasure was but had been
the offspring of nature's dotage and
always the grade decrepit sapless
miserable creatures who now sat stooping
round the doctor's table without life
enough in their souls or bodies to be
animated even by the prospect of growing
young again they drank off the water and
replace their glasses on the table
assuredly there was an almost immediate
improvement in the aspect of the party
not unlike what might have been produced
by a glass of generous wine together
with a sudden glow of cheerful sunshine
brightening over all their visages at
once
there was a healthful suffusion on their
cheeks instead of the ashen hue that had
made them look so corpse like they gazed
at one another and fancied that some
magic power had really begun to smooth
away the deep and sad inscriptions which
father time had been so long engraving
on their brows the widow wicker Lee
adjusted her cap for she felt almost
like a woman again
give us more of this wondrous water
cried they eagerly we are younger but we
are still too old quick give us more
patience patience and dr. Heidegger who
sat watching the experiment with
philosophic coolness you have been a
long time growing old surely you might
be content to grow young in half an hour
but the water is at your service again
he filled their glasses with the liquor
of youth enough of which still remained
in the vase to turn half the old people
in the city to the age of their own
grandchildren while the bubbles were yet
sparkling on the brim the doctors for
guests snatched their glasses from the
table and swallowed the contents at a
single gulp was it delusion even while
the draught was passing down their
throats it seemed to have brought a
change on their whole systems their eyes
grew clear and bright a dark shade
deepened among the silvery locks they
sat around the table three gentlemen and
middle-aged and a woman hardly beyond
her buxom prime my dear Widow you were
charming cried Colonel Killigrew whose
eyes had been fixed upon her face while
the shadows of age were flitting from it
like darkness from the crimson daybreak
the fair widow knew of old that Colonel
killebrew's compliments were not always
measured by sober truth so she started
up and ran to the mirror still dreading
that the ugly visit of an old woman
would meet her gaze meanwhile the three
gentlemen behaved in such a manner as
proved that the water of the Fountain of
Youth possessed some intoxicating
qualities unless indeed their
exhilaration of spirits were merely
alight some dizziness caused by the
sudden removal of the weight of years Mr
Gascoigne's mind seemed to run on
political topics but whether relating to
the past present or future could not be
easily determined since the same ideas
and phrases have been in vogue these
fifty years now he rattled forth
full-throated sentences about patriotism
national glory and the people's right
now
he muttered some perilous stuff or other
in a sly and doubtful whisper so
cautiously that even his own conscience
could scare Lee catch the secret and now
again he spoke in measured accents and a
deeply deferential tone as if a royal
ear were listening to his well turned
periods Colonel Killigrew all this time
had been trolling for that jolly bottle
song and bringing his glass in Symphony
with the chorus while his eyes wandered
toward the buxom figure of the widow
wicker Lee on the other side of the
table mr. med borne was involved in a
calculation of dollars and cents with
which was strangely intermingled a
project for supplying the East Indies
with ice by harnessing a team of whales
to the polar icebergs as for the widow
wicker Lee she stood before the mirror
curtseying and simpering to her own
image and greeting it as the friend whom
she loved better than all the world
beside she thrust her face close to the
glass to see whether some long
remembered wrinkled or crows foot had
indeed vanished she examined whether the
snow had so entirely melted from her
hair that the venerable cap could be
safely thrown aside at last
turning briskly away she came with a
sort of dancing step to the table my
dear old doctor cried she pray favor me
with another glass certainly my dear
Madame certainly replied the complacent
doctor see I have already filled the
glasses there in fact stood the four
glasses brim full of this wonderful
water the delicate spray of which has it
ever vest from the surface resembled the
tremulous glitter of diamonds it was now
so nearly sunset that the chamber had
grown duskier than ever but a mild and
moonlight splendour gleamed from within
the vase and rested alike on the four
guests and on the doctor's venerable
figure he sat in a high back to laborat
leak armed oaken armchair with a great
dignity of aspect that might have well
befitted that very father time whose
power had never been disputed saved by
this fortunate company even while
quaffing the third draft of the Fountain
of Youth
they were almost awed by the expression
of his mysterious visit for the next
moment the exhilarating gush of young
life shot through their veins they were
now in the happy prime of youth age with
its miserable train of cares and sorrows
and dizzy
was remembered only as the trouble of a
dream from which they had joyously awoke
the fresh gloss of the soul so early
lost and without the world's successive
scenes had been but a gallery of faded
pictures again through its enchantment
over all their prospects they felt like
new created beings in a new created
universe we are young we are young they
cried exulting lee youths like the
extremity of age had a face the strongly
marked characteristics of middle life
and mutually assimilated them all they
were a group of merry youngsters almost
maddened with the exuberant frolicsome
Ness of their years the most singular
effect of their gaiety was an impulse to
mock the infirmity and decrepitude of
which they had so lately been the
victims they laughed loudly at their
old-fashioned attire the wide skirted
coats and flapped waistcoat to the young
men and the ancient cap and gown of the
blooming girl one limped across the
floor like a gaudi grandfather one set a
pair of spectacles astride of his nose
and pretended to pour over the black
letter pages of the book of magic
a third seated himself in an armchair
and strove to imitate the venerable
dignity of dr. Heidegger then all
shouted mirthfully and leaped about the
room the widow wicker Lee if so fresh a
damsel could be called a widow tripped
up to the doctor's chair with a
mischievous merriment in her rosy face
doctor you dear old soul cried she get
up and dance with me and then the for
young people laughed louder than ever to
think what a queer figure the poor old
doctor would cut pray excuse me answered
the doctor quietly I'm old and rheumatic
and my dancing days were over long ago
but either of these gay young gentlemen
would be glad of so pretty a partner
dance with me Clara cried Colonel
Killigrew no no I will be her partner
shouted mr. Gascoigne she promised me
her hand fifty years ago exclaimed mr.
med born they all gathered round her one
caught both her hands and his passionate
grasp another threw his arm about her
waist the third buried his hand among
the glossy curls that clustered beneath
the widow's cap blushing panting
struggling chiding laughing her warm
breath Fanning each of their faces by
turns she strove to disengage herself
still remained in their triple embrace
never was there a livelier picture of
youthful rival ship with bewitching
beauty for the prize yet by a strange
deception oh into the duskiness of the
chamber and the antique dresses which
they still wore the tall mirror is said
to have reflected the figures of the
three old gray withered grandsire's
ridiculously contending for the skinny
ugliness of a shriveled grand-am but
they were young their burning passions
proved them so inflamed to madness by
the coquetry of the girl widow who
neither granted nor quite withheld her
favors the three rivals began to
interchange threatening glances still
keeping hold that the fair prize they
grappled fiercely at one another's
throats as they struggled to and fro the
table was overturned and the vase dashed
into a thousand fragments the precious
water of youth flowed in a bright stream
across the floor moistening the wings of
a butterfly which grown old in the
decline of summer had alighted there to
die the insect fluttered lightly through
the chamber and settled on the snowy
head of dr. Heidegger come come
gentlemen come Madame Wieck early
exclaimed a doctor I really must protest
against this riot they stood still and
shivered for it seemed as if gray time
were calling them back from their sunny
youth far down into the chill and dark
Sun veil of years they looked at old dr.
Heidegger who sat in his carved armchair
holding the rows of half a century which
he had rescued from among the fragments
of the shattered vase at the motion of
his hand the four rioters resumed their
seats the more readily because their
violent exertions had wearied them
youthful though they were my poor
Sylvia's rose said dr. Heidegger holding
it in the light of the sunset clouds it
appears to be fading again and so it was
even while the party was looking at it
the flower continued to shrivel up till
it became as dry and fragile as when the
doctor had first thrown it into the vase
he shook off the few drops of moisture
which clung to its petals I love it as
well fuss as in its dewy freshness
observed he pressing the withered rose
to his withered lips while he spoke the
butterfly fluttered down from the
doctors snowy head
and fell upon the floor his guests
shivered again a strange chillness
whether at the body or spirit they could
not tell was creeping gradually over
them all they gazed at one another and
fancied that each fleeting moment
snatched away a charm and left a
deepening furrow where none had been
before
was it an illusion had the changes of a
lifetime been crowded into so brief a
space and were they now for aged people
sitting with their old friend dr.
Heidegger are we grown old again so soon
cried they dolefully in truths they had
the water of youth possessed merely a
virtue more transient than that of wine
the delirium which it created had ever
vest away yes they were old again with a
shuddering impulse that showed her a
woman still the widow clasped her skinny
hands before her face and wished that
the coffin lid were over it since it
could no longer be beautiful yes friends
you were old again said dr. Heidegger
and look the water of youth is all
lavished on the ground well I been mown
it not for if the fountain gushed at my
very doorstep I would not stoop to bathe
my lips in it no though it's delirium
were four years instead of moments such
as the lesson you have taught me but the
doctors for friends had taught no such
lesson to themselves they resolved
forthwith to make a pilgrimage to
Florida and quaff at morning noon and
night from the Fountain of Youth
all space is relative there's no such
thing as size the telescope and the
microscope have produced a deadly
leveling of great and small far and near
the only little thing is sin the only
great thing is fear for the hundredth
time professor quarreling repeated his
statement and for the hundredth time we
listened in silence afraid to enter into
a controversy with him it was not the
fact that he knew more than we did that
kept us quiet but the haunting fear that
filled us when we listened to him or
watched him at work
working in an unsolved problem he seemed
the soul detached a spirit separated
from its earthly home a being living
only in the realm of thought his body
sat motionless his eyes catatonic
unwinking stared until his mind
satisfied deign to return to bone bound
cell then in magnificent condescension
he would talk freely in limpid phrases
of the things he had considered and the
conclusions he had deduced we chosen
scientists University graduates hailed
him as our master and hated him for
admitting his mastery we hoped some evil
might befall him and yet we admitted
that the success of our expedition
depended upon his continued leadership
it was vitally necessary for our future
we were struggling young men with all
life ahead of us and if we failed in our
first effort there would be no other
opportunities for fame granted to us in
a specially constructed yacht a
veritable floating laboratory we were
south of Borneo making a detailed study
of microscopic sea life in deep-sea nets
we gathered the tiny organisms and then
with microscope photography and the
cinema we observe them for the future
instruction of the human race
there were hundreds of species thousands
of varieties each to be identified
classified described studied and
photographed we gathered in the morning
studied until midnight and slept
restlessly till morning the only thing
in which we were agreed was ambition our
soul united emotion was hatred of the
professor he knew how we felt and
enjoyed taunting us I am your leader
because I willed it so he would say
speaking in a low restrained voice with
me the will to attain is synonymous with
accomplishment I believe in myself and
through this irreducible faith I succeed
there is nothing a strong man cannot do
if he wills to do it and believes in his
strength our ideas of space size and
time are but the fanciful dreams of
children I am fifty nine inches tall and
fully clothed weigh 110 pounds if I
desired I could make myself a colossus
and swallow the earth as a child swallow
as a pill if I willed it I could fly
through space like a comet or hang
suspended in the ether like the morning
star my will is greater than any other
physical force because I believe in it I
have confidence in my ability to do
whatever I wish so far I have conducted
myself like an average man because I
desire to so behave and not because of
any limitations man has a soul and that
ethereal force is greater than any law
of nature that man ever thought of or
any God ever created
he is purely and totally supreme if he
so desires
it was after such a defiant declaration
to us that our chemist Bullard gathered
courage to challenge his power he stated
his opinion sharply and to the point I
do not believe you what is that to me
answered the professor simply this you
make a statement that you have certain
powers I say that it is not true of what
good to boast if you know we think you a
liar can you do these things if you can
do them for us and I for one will hail
you as greater than God fail to do them
and I will brand you a boasting Powe
zero
the professor looked steadily at the
chemist we waited breathlessly for the
blow to fall but he only laughed you
want to sign a proof I thought of just
such a thing and I would have proposed
it myself had one of you not asked for
it the thing must be visible to all of
you something that I can demonstrate a
thing unheard-of and act all men
consider impossible and yet I will do it
listen to me you have all seen the
jellyfish called the bishops miter when
it is magnified 300 times under the
microscope it looks like a small balloon
with a large opening at one end it
propels itself through the water by the
flagellate movement of its cilia the
walls are translucent and transparent at
the top there are two specialized groups
of nerve cells which we believe may
serve as eyes the opening at the bottom
serves as a mouth smaller cells enter
there and are absorbed I describe it to
refresh your memory though you have all
seen it I will secure one in a hanging
drop under the microscope and then we
will attach the camera and cinema to it
we will project the picture on our
screen you will see the miter move and
live you will observe the cilia move
while we have the actual specimen under
observation I will look at it through
the microscope then I will demonstrate
to you that I'm not the idle boaster you
thank me I will force myself to pass
through the glass eyepiece down into the
brass tube as I go I will make myself
grow smaller finally I will pass through
the objective and jump into the hanging
drop I will swim in that drop swim up to
the jellyfish and touch it make actual
observations concerning its structure
and functions while I am in the drop of
water you will be able to observe my
every motion on the screen then I will
disappear pass through the microscope
upwards and finally resume my original
size and position in the room I presume
that if I do this you will be satisfied
we were too astonished to reply it was
evident that the man had suddenly become
insane he smiled superciliously as
though we were children
he waited for an answer but we had none
and then he began to prepare the
apparatus for the experiment finally all
was to his satisfaction after examining
several drops of water from our specimen
jar he was able to imprison a bishops
mitre in the hanging drop under the
microscope he switched on the
electricity and we saw the jellyfish
move upon the screen
the professor carefully adjusted the
apparatus until the organism appeared
with more than usual distinctness we saw
the little animal he had so carefully
described to us we even saw the little
projections which we believed were it's
rudimentary visual organs then professor
choir Ling told the cinema operator what
he wanted done he was to take a picture
starting from the time the professor
disappeared down the brass tube of the
microscope and continue until he
reappeared no matter what happened he
was to go on taking pictures it is all
well enough said our master for you
children to see what is happening and to
talk about it later on but who would
believe you we know that the camera
cannot lie that is why it is important
to take a consecutive picture of what
occurs otherwise you might think that
I've been able to hypnotize you now I
will look down this tube at the bottom
of the hanging drop I see a transparent
balloon it is a pretty sight now watch
me carefully as I will myself to shrink
I will go on talking as long as I can
and you must listen carefully because
the smaller I am the less audible will
be my voice now I am 12 inches high I am
standing near the microscope I grow
still smaller and now I'm only one inch
tall and I'm standing on the eyepiece no
doubt you can barely hear me now I am
smaller yet and I'm ready to will myself
through the glass of the eyepiece the
room became silent shivering we looked
at the microscope the professor was gone
the chemist staggered over to the
instrument looked into it and silently
reeled back to his seat on the screen
before us the living inhabitants of the
drop of water lived and moved and had
their being largest of all was the
transparent jellyfish which was moving
restlessly as those seeking a way of
escape the only sound in the room was
the hum of the cinema and the stertorous
breathing of the chemist
then on the screen came a new figure we
were able to identify as the professor
swimming among the infusoria gaining his
balance at last he stood upright and
waved his hand at us it was easy to see
his smile that condescending smug smile
that it so often driven us frantic there
was no doubt from his expression that he
was highly pleased with his performance
none of us dared look at his fellow not
one of the audience thought for a second
of taking his eyes off the silver screen
we were stunned stupefied and filled
with a wild terror all the more horrible
because of the silence the professor
started to swim again and now approached
the jellyfish he tapped the crystal
walls then as though seized with a
sudden impulse he went to the bottom
jumped up through the mouth and entered
the translucent ball of protoplasm he
peered at us through the transparent
walls his arms made a series of peculiar
movements and once again he smiled at us
my god exclaimed the artist he's wig
bagging to us an army code he says I
have done it and now I will return to
your world as though to keep his promise
he started for the mouth of the
jellyfish and then the mouth closed
the professor circled the glass like
balls seeking a way of exit once he
waved at us in a peculiar manner and
then suddenly he sought the wall and
with arms and feet tried to break
through on his face was now the look of
ghastly despair the things on top of the
jellyfish began to glow no doubt now
that they were eyes and bright ones
before our eyes the professor slowly
disappeared into a globule of milky
protoplasm the jellyfish not only had
made him a prisoner but it actually
dissolved and digested him with a shriek
the artist went over to the wall and
turned on the electric lights trembling
the chemists looked down the tube of the
microscope and told us that there was
nothing in the hanging drop saved the
jellyfish the next day after a
conference in which each of us said only
part of what he thought we decided to
destroy the roll of film and sent word
to the university that the professor had
disappeared from the ship and our only
explanation was that he had been drowned
of course I shall not pretend to
consider it any matter for wonder that
the extraordinary case of M Valdemar has
excited discussion it would have been a
miracle had it not especially under the
circumstances through the desire of all
parties concerned to keep the affair
from the public at least for the present
or until we had further opportunities
for investigation through our endeavors
to effect this a garbled or exaggerated
account made its way into society and
became the source of many unpleasant
misrepresentations and very naturally of
a great deal of disbelief it is now
rendered necessary that I give the facts
as far as I comprehend them myself
they are succinctly these my attention
for the last three years had been
repeatedly drawn to the subject of
mesmerism and about nine months ago it
occurred to me quite suddenly that in
the series of experiments made hitherto
there had been a very remarkable and
most unaccountable omission no person
had as yet been mesmerised in articulo
mortis it remained to be seen first
whether in such a condition there
existed in the patient any
susceptibility to the magnetic influence
secondly whether if any existed it was
impaired or increased by the condition
thirdly to what extent or for how long a
period the encroachments of death might
be arrested by the process there were
other points to be ascertained
but these most excited my curiosity the
last in a special from the immensely
important character of its consequences
in looking around me for some subject by
whose means I might test these
particulars I was brought to think of my
friend M earnest Valdemar the well-known
compiler of the bibliotheca forensic ax
and author under the nom de plume of
Issachar Mars of the Polish versions of
Valen Stein and gargantuan M Valdemar
who was resided principally at Harlem
New York since the year 1839
or was particularly noticeable for
extreme spareness of his person his
lower limbs much resembling those of
John Randolph and also for the whiteness
of his whiskers in violent contrast to
the blackness of his hair the latter and
consequence being very generally
mistaken for a wig his temperament was
markedly nervous and rendered him a good
subject for mesmeric experiment on two
or three occasions I had put him to
sleep with little difficulty but was
disappointed and other results which his
peculiar Constitution had naturally led
me to anticipate his will was at no
period positively or thoroughly under my
control and in regard to clairvoyance I
could accomplish with him nothing to be
relied upon
I always attributed my failure at these
points to the disordered state of his
health for some months previous to my
becoming acquainted with him his
physicians had declared him in a
confirmed thesis it was his custom
indeed to speak calmly of his
approaching disillusion as a matter
neither to be avoided nor regretted when
the ideas to which I have alluded first
occurred to me it was of course very
natural that I should think of M
Valdemar I knew the steady philosophy of
the man to well to apprehend any
scruples from him and he had no
relatives in America who would be likely
to interfere I spoke to him frankly upon
the subject and to my surprise his
interest seemed vividly excited I say to
my surprise for although he had always
yielded his person freely to my
experiments he had never before given me
any tokens of sympathy with what I did
his disease was of that character which
would admit of exact calculation and
respect to the epoch of its termination
and death and it was finally arranged
between us that he would send for me
about 24 hours before the period
announced by his physicians as that of
his decease it is now rather more than
seven months since I received from
Valdemar himself thus of joined note my
dear friend you may as well come now my
doctors are agreed that I cannot hold
out beyond tomorrow midnight and I think
they have hit the time very nearly
Valdemar I received this note within
half an hour after it was written and in
fifteen minutes more I was in the dying
man's chamber I had not seen him for ten
days
and was appalled by the fearful
alteration which the brief interval had
wrought in him his face were a leaden
hue his eyes were utterly lustreless and
the emaciation was so extreme that the
skin had been broken through by the
cheekbones his expectoration was
excessive the pulse was barely
perceptible he retained nevertheless in
a very remarkable manner both his mental
power and a certain degree of physical
strength
he spoke with distinctness took some
palliative medicines without aid and
when I entered the room was occupied in
penciling memoranda in a pocketbook
he was propped up in the bed by pillows
the doctors were in attendance after
pressing valdemar's hand I took these
gentlemen aside and obtained from them a
minut account of the patient's condition
the left lung had been for 18 months in
a semi osseous or cartilaginous state
and was of course entirely useless for
all purposes of vitality the right in
its upper portion was also partially if
not thoroughly ossified while the lower
region was merely a mass of pure eula
tubercles running into one another
several extensive perforations existed
and at one point permitted adhesion to
the ribs had taken place these
appearances in the right lobe were of
comparatively recent date the
ossification had preceded with very
unusual rapidity no sign of it had been
discovered a month before and the
adhesion had only been observed during
the three previous days independently of
the thesis the patient was suspected of
aneurysm of the aorta but on this point
the osseous symptoms rendered an exact
diagnosis impossible it was the opinion
of both physicians that M Valdemar would
die about midnight on the morrow Sunday
it was then seven o'clock on Saturday
evening on quitting the invalids bedside
to hold conversation with myself the
doctors had bidden him a final farewell
it had not been their intention to
return but at my request they agreed to
look in upon the patient about 10:00 the
next night when they had gone I spoke
freely without Valdemar on the subject
of his approaching disillusion as well
as more particularly of the experiment
proposed he still professed himself
quite willing and even anxious to have
it made
and urged me to commence it at once a
male and a female nurse were in
attendance but I did not feel myself
altogether at liberty to engage in a
task of this character with no more
reliable witnesses than these people in
case of sudden accident might prove I
therefore postponed operations until
about 8:00 the next night when the
arrival of a medical student with whom I
had some acquaintance mr. Theodore
relieved me from further embarrassment
it had been my design originally to wait
for the physicians but I was induced to
proceed first by the urgent and treatise
of M Valdemar and secondly by my
conviction that I had not a moment to
lose as he was evidently sinking fast
mr. Theodore was so kind as to accede to
my desire that he would take notes of
all that occurred and it is from his
memoranda that what I now have to relate
is for the most part either condensed or
copied verbatim it wanted about five
minutes of eight when taking the
patient's hand I begged him to state as
distinctively as he could to mr.
Theodore whether he and Valdemar was
entirely willing that I should make the
experiment of mesmerizing him in his
then condition he replied feebly yet
quite audibly yes I wish to be
mesmerised adding immediately afterward
I fear you have deferred it too long
while he spoke thus I commenced the
passes which I had already found most
effectual in subduing him he was
evidently influenced with the first
lateral stroke of my hand across his
forehead but although I exerted all my
powers no further perceptible effect was
induced until some minutes after ten
o'clock when the doctors called
according to appointment I explained to
them in a few words what I designed and
as they opposed no objection saying that
the patient was already in the death
agony I proceeded without hesitation
exchanging however the lateral passes
for downward ones and directing my gaze
entirely into the right eye of the
sufferer by this time his pulse was
imperceptible and his breathing was
stertorous
and at intervals of half a minute this
condition was nearly unaltered for a
quarter of an hour at the expiration of
this period however unnatural although a
very deep sigh escaped the bosom of the
dying man and the stertorous breathing
ceased that is to say it stirred
this was no longer apparent the
intervals were undiminished the
patient's extremities were of an icy
coldness at five minutes before 11:00 I
perceived unequivocal signs of the
mesmeric influence the glassy role of
the eye was changed for that expression
of uneasy inward examination which has
never seen except in cases of sleep
waking and which it is quite impossible
to mistake with a few rapid lateral
passes I made the lids quiver as an
incipient sleep and with a few more I
closed them altogether I was not
satisfied however with this but
continued the manipulations vigorously
and with the fullest exertion of the
will until I had completely stiffened
the limbs of the slumbers after placing
them in a seemingly easy position the
legs were at full length the arms were
nearly so and reposed on the bed at a
moderate distance from the loins the
head was very slightly elevated when I
had accomplished this it was fully
midnight and I requested the gentleman
present to examine and valdemar's
condition after a few experiments they
admitted him to be in an unusually
perfect state of mesmeric trance the
curiosity of both physicians was greatly
excited one of the doctors resolved at
once to remain with the patient all
night while the other took leave with a
promise to return at daybreak mr.
Theodore and the nurses remained we left
M Valdemar entirely undisturbed until
about three o'clock in the morning when
I approached him and found him in
precisely the same condition as when the
doctor went away that is to say he lay
in the same position the pulse was
imperceptible the breathing was gentle
scarcely noticeable and less through the
application of a mirror to the lips the
eyes were closed naturally and the limbs
were as rigid and as cold as marble
still the general appearance was
certainly not that of death as I
approached M Bal de Mar I made a kind of
half effort to influence his right arm
into pursuit of my own as I passed the
ladder gently to and fro above his
person in such experiments with this
patient I had never perfectly succeeded
before and assuredly I had little
thought of succeeding now but to my
astonishment has armed very readily
although feebly followed every direction
I assigned it
with mine I determined to hazard a few
words of conversation and Valdemar I
said are you asleep he made no answer
but I perceived a tremor about the lips
and was thus induced to repeat the
question again and again at its third
repetition his whole frame was agitated
by a very slight shivering the eyelids
unclosed themselves so far as to display
a white line of a ball the lips moved
sluggishly and from between them in a
barely audible whisper issued the words
yes asleep now do not wake me let me die
so I hear felt the limbs and found them
as bridgette as ever the right arm as
before obeyed the direction of my hand I
questioned the sleep/wake err again do
you still feel pain in the breast M
Valdemar the answer now was immediate
but even less audible than before no
pain I am dying I did not think it
advisable to disturb him further just
then and nothing more was said or done
until the arrival of the second doctor
who came a little before sunrise and
expressed unbounded astonishment at
finding the patient's still alive after
feeling the pulse and applying a mirror
to the lips he requested me to speak to
the sleep/wake ER again I did so saying
M Valdemar do you still sleep as before
some minutes elapsed IRRI reply was made
and during the interval the dying man
seemed to be collecting his energies to
speak at my fourth repetition of the
question he said very faintly almost
inaudibly yes still asleep dying it was
now the opinion or rather the wish of
the physicians that M Valdemar should be
suffered to remain undisturbed in his
present apparently tranquil condition
until death should supervene and this it
was generally agreed must now take place
within a few minutes I concluded however
to speak to him once more and merely
repeated my previous question while I
spoke there came a market change over
the countenance of the sleep/wake er the
eyes rolled themselves slowly open the
pupils disappearing upwardly the skin
generally assumed a cadaverous hue
resembling not so much parchment as
white paper and the circular hectic
spots which hitherto had been strongly
defined in the center of each cheek when
at once I used this expression because
the suddenness of their departure put me
in mind of nothing so much as the
extinguishment of a candle by a puff of
the breath the upper lip at the same
time bribed itself away from the teeth
which it had previously covered
completely while the lower jaw fell with
an audible jerk leaving the mouth widely
extended and disclosing in full view the
swollen and blackened tongue I presume
that no member the party then present
had been unaccustomed to deathbed
horrors but so hideous beyond conception
was the appearance of M Valdemar at this
moment that there was a general
shrinking back from the region of the
bed I now feel that I've reached a point
of this narrative at which every reader
will be startled into positive disbelief
it is my business however simply to
proceed there was no longer the faintest
sign of vitality in M Valdemar and
concluding him to be dead
we were consigning him to the charge of
the nurses when a strong vibratory
motion was observable in the tongue this
continued for perhaps a minute at the
expiration of this period there issued
from the distended and motionless jaws a
voice such as it would be madness in me
to attempt describing there are indeed
two or three epithets which might be
considered as applicable to it in part I
might say for example that the sound was
harsh
and broken and hollow but the hideous
hole is indescribable for the simple
reason that no similar sounds have ever
jarred upon the ear of humanity there
were two particulars nevertheless which
I thought then and still think might
fairly be stated as characteristic of
the intonation as well adapted to convey
some idea of its unearthly peculiarity
in the first place the voice seemed to
reach our ears at least mine from a vast
distance or from some deep cavern within
the earth in the second place it
impressed me I fear indeed that it will
be impossible to make myself
comprehended as gelatinous or glutinous
matters impressed the sense of touch I
have spoke both of sound and a voice I
mean to say that the sound was one of
distinct I've even wonderfully
thrillingly distinct syllabication and
Valdemar spoke obviously in reply to the
question I had propounded to him a few
minutes before I
asked him it will be remembered if he
still slept he now said yes no I have
been sleeping and now now I am dead no
person present even affected to deny or
attempted to repress the unutterable
shuddering horror which these few words
thus uttered were so well calculated to
convey mr. Theodore the student swooned
the nurses immediately left the chamber
and could not be induced to return my
own impressions I would not pretend to
render intelligible to the reader for
nearly an hour we busied ourselves
silently without the utterance of a word
in endeavours to revive mr. Theodore
when he came to himself we addressed
ourselves again to an investigation of M
valdemar's condition it remained in all
respects as I have at last described it
with the exception that the mirror no
longer afforded evidence of respiration
an attempt to draw blood from the arm
failed I should mention too that this
limb was no farther subject to my will I
endeavoured in vain to make it follow
the direction of my hand
the only real indication indeed of the
mesmeric influence was now found in the
vibratory movement of the tongue when
ever I addressed M balde amar a question
he seemed to be making an effort to
reply but had no longer sufficient
politian to queries put to him by any
other person than myself he seemed
utterly insensible although I
endeavoured to place each member of the
company in mesmeric rapport with him I
believe that I have now related all that
is necessary to an understanding of the
sleep/wake ER state at this epoch other
nurses were procured and at ten o'clock
I left the house and company with the to
physicians and mr. Theodore in the
afternoon we all called again to see the
patient
his condition remained precisely the
same we had now some discussion as to
the propriety and feasibility of
awakening him but we had little
difficulty in agreeing that no good
purpose would be served by so doing it
was evident that so far death or what is
usually termed death had been arrested
by the mesmeric process it seemed clear
to us all that to awaken and Valdemar
would be merely to ensure his instant or
at least his speedy disillusion
from this period until the close of last
week an interval of nearly seven months
we continue to make daily calls at M
valdemar's house accompanied now and
then by medical and other friends all
this time the sleep/wake have remained
exactly as I have at last described him
the nurse's attentions were continual it
was on Friday last that we finally
resolved to make the experiment of
awakening or attempting to awaken him
and it is the perhaps unfortunate result
of this latter experiment which has
given rise to so much discussion in
private circles to so much of what I
cannot help thinking unwarranted popular
feeling for the purpose of relieving M
Valdemar from the mesmeric trance I made
use of the customary passes these for a
time were unsuccessful the first
indication of revival was afforded by a
partial descent of the iris it was
observed as especially remarkable that
this lowering of the pupil was
accompanied by the perfuse outflowing of
a yellowish eye core from beneath the
lids of a pungent and highly offensive
odor
it was now suggested that I should
attempt to influence the patient's arm
as heretofore I made the attempt and
failed one of the doctors that intimated
a desire to have me put a question I did
so as follows and Valdemar can you
explain to us what are your feelings or
wishes now there was an instant return
of the hectic circles on the cheeks the
tongue quivered are rather rolled
violently in the mouth although the jaws
and lips remained rigid as before and at
length the same hideous voice which I
have already described broke forth for
God's sake quick quick put me to sleep
or quick waken me quick I say to you
that I am dead
I was thoroughly unnerved and for an
instant remained undecided what to do at
first I made an endeavor to recompose
the patient but failing in this through
total abeyance of the will I retraced my
steps and has earnestly struggled to
awaken him in this attempt I soon saw
that I should be successful or at least
I soon fancied that my success would be
complete and I am sure that all in the
room were prepared to see the patient
awaken for what really occurred however
it is quite impossible that any human
being could have been prepared as I
rapidly made the mesmeric passes amid
ejaculations of dead dead absolutely
bursting from the tongue and not from
the lips of the sufferer his whole frame
at once was in the space of a single
minute or even less shrunk crumbled
absolutely rotted away beneath my hands
upon the bed before that whole company
there lay a nearly liquid mass of loot
'some of detestable putrescence
you